huge that's a british pace blasted
parliament leader jacob rees-mogg for
opposing unicef feeding poor families in
the uk for the first time
rhys mogg of the ruling conservative
party had claimed unicef's food relief
was just a publicity stunt
the real scandal that unicef should be
playing politics in this way when it is
meant to be looking after
people in the poorest the most deprived
countries in the world where people are
starving where there are famines and
where there are civil wars
and they make cheap political points of
this kind
giving i think twenty five thousand
pounds to one council it is a political
stunt
in parliament i just challenged jacob
free smoke about unicef having to feed
working-class kids in the uk
it's shameful for kids to go hungry it's
not shameful to feed them
the only person who should be ashamed is
you mr rhys mock
so unicef recently launched a
wide-ranging program aimed at tackling
food insecurity it'll be granting up to
seven hundred thousand pounds to
community groups all over the uk
the organization is also helping feed
children in the south of london as
mentioned
giving out food parcels and assuring
breakfast is distributed to
schools there and of course the
campaign's put a big spotlight then on
the general picture of food poverty in
the uk considered one of the wealthiest
countries in the world
according to unicef 2.4 million children
live
in so-called food insecure homes free
school
meal programs have seen huge numbers of
families sign up
unicef's defended its decision to
provide humanitarian help to children in
the uk
unicef uk is responding to this
unprecedented crisis
and building on our 25 years experience
of working on children's rights in the
uk
with a one-off domestic response
launched in august to provide support
to vulnerable children and families
around the country during this crisis
period
early we spoke with the founder of
britain's largest independent food bank
who says the government's handling of
the poverty crisis has been unacceptable
i think the reality is the government's
own figures show that in britain
4.5 children get million children get
free school meals
and before the pandemic the government's
own figures confirmed that 12 million
people in britain were in poverty
i think what unicef have done is of
course
given some money to people in britain
and britain
is one of the great generous countries
in the world for giving money
so it's only just right that when our
people are in crisis that that unicef
gives us some cash back
the scandal is we have a government that
keeps pussyfooting
around the real crisis in britain and
that's 15
000 people 15 million people in the
sixth richest economy on the planet
going hungry
and that's not acceptable we should be
leading a global campaign
to end poverty not pussyfooting around
it uh we now
feeding so many people we can hardly
cope it's not something that we can just
depend anymore on our government our
government
around the world are all tied up with
the pandemic trying to get people
safe and stop people dying letting
people go hungry is not a priority
and so we as people and we as
communities need to take back that power
and politicize it in a way that we can
uh
eradicate the problems
you